nous allons parler de la chine oui de la
chine et plus précisément de l'essor
économique fulgurant du pays
textile informatique automobile depuis
près de 40 ans les produits chinois ont
conquis la planète
inarrêtable le géant chinois depuis la
fin des années soixante dix la course
développement économique décidés par
deng xiaoping n'a cessé de s'accélérer
la chine est aujourd'hui lé usine du
monde est un partenaire économique
incontournable un bond en avant rendue
possible par une croissance vertigineuse
depuis les années 70 le pib est
multiplié par deux tous les dix ans il
s'envole ensuite à partir des années
2000 pour dépasser les 12200 37
milliards de dollars l'année dernière
cette expansion chinoise certains
avaient prédite en 1973 l'homme d'état
alain peyrefitte prévenait quand la
chine s'éveillera le monde tremblera
pense que la chine maintenant est entré
dans le monde moderne elle est devenue
notre contemporaine et nous ne pouvons
pas
inhumé à l'ignorer comme nous l'avons
fait
juste après
dans les années soixante dix la chine
comptait quelques 818 millions
d'habitants une force pour le pays car
c'est sur cette importante population
que miss certaines entreprises locales
et internationales
une forte main d'oeuvre à des prix
imbattables cette entreprise avec 300
employés produit plus de 15 sans
pantalon par jour et plus de 2500
chemise dans la même journée
tout est organisé pour un rendement
optimum avec un matériel sophistiqué et
ironie ces belles machines ont été
conçus construits et installés par les
européens eux mêmes et aujourd'hui les
moyens de production sont encore plus
importants la chine compte à ce jour 1,3
milliard d'habitants et résultats la
chine devient la première économie de la
planète c'est ce que montrent les
derniers calculs du fonds monétaire
international alain peyrefitte avait
donc raison
la chine s'est bel et bien éveillé une
première place qui est loin de réjouir
tout le monde
détrôné les états unis n'entendent pas
se laisser faire
[Musique]